what up
[Applause]
thank you thank you
we are here early
on this beautiful friday well early
yeah come on you're right you're right
already early then normal i mean we're
not that late that we've been worse but
like yeah we're here early today because
we come here today
it is mine and ila's ninth anniversary
this weekend
[Applause]
not it wasn't too bad
i was willing to stick it out for as
long as it took
yeah
for sure i'm definitely slower in the
morning so oh
i feel that i have a slow response time
i feel that girl
if people think i'm normally slow
mm-hmm you're not normally slow you
would say that not easy no ricegum
ricegum
that guy's made of that guy's literally
made of rubber i mean he moved he's he's
gumby in real life how is he
how is he gonna tell anyone slow
you know
but anyway we're here early because we
are taking a trip this weekend
to celebrate
and um we need a little bit of extra
time which also means that on
monday we will not be having a h3 tv
instead it will be being moved to
tuesday thank you thank you peace and
love
and love happy anniversary almost stila
what's today so two more days there
all right nine years huh nine years
[Music]
yeah you know
time flies by man yeah that's i was um
just
talking about it this morning like uh
this nine years
it's crazy what i've gone through that
what we've been through yeah it's both a
lot it's both was fat i think it wasn't
really it was a lot i feel like it was a
different lifetime yeah it was a lot if
you think back to where we were when we
first got married
i was working
you were in school yeah
our youtube channel made it was in its
infancy we had like 500 subs or
something maybe i don't think we were
even doing it regularly yet like yeah
yeah
um
yeah i mean i was skinny
[ __ ] rip
but it's been a good time man
and now and now we're parents i know i
was just i was thinking in the shower
the other day i was like
anything that led
obviously our marriage has been nothing
but good
for in life i mean i think it's fanta i
think it's been great every time i every
time i go to therapy it's like
they kind of fish for like dirt oh yeah
they do the same to me
they're like so what you know and i'm
like all good there
yeah they do the same thing to me
because it's like you know you got
issues with your spouse just tell me
what the [ __ ] is up that's why you're
here right
i'm like no there's no problems with her
it's actually my dad yeah
no whatever yeah
yeah
my relationship with my wife is great
yeah but anything that could have led to
a theodore existing
has got to be the mo the best thing uh
that's ever happened to me
yeah whatever road led to him exists you
know what i mean lately he's so funny
he's been so talkative he's a little
comedian yeah
she's just like making everyone laugh
all day and he lately he goes like
he crunches up his face when he's
thinking hard
like what are you doing guys yeah what
you doing guys
what you talking about guys yeah we'll
be having a conversation on a walk up
what you talking about guys
what you're wearing daddy like he's
totally he's gotta know everything he's
doing on your phone daddy
oh and he started going why like we went
down the wide name hole now oh my god
it's like uh
theodore look there's a there's a bush
shaped like a dinosaur why yeah because
they cut it that way why
why and he says it like that
why well because they thought it would
be cool to cut the bush that way why
well people have different preferences
and um it will go on like
you know
i like to entertain it because
he is it is he's not yanking my chain he
it's a genuine pursuit of knowledge yeah
because sometimes he'll ask when he's
satisfied he'll stop asking when he's
satisfied
well oh it's just people's preferences
why
well people you know they're born and
the environment affects them and you
know everybody's a little different
because their parents and their
environment why
well if you go back to the evolutionary
explanation of how human beings were
formed
you know the biology dictates that each
person is relatively
unique due to their environmental
services why
well well after the big bang
that's great yeah
by the way sponsored by hellofresh and
kraken oh speaking of hello
legendary human beings where are we
today gabe
i'm at the dry cleaners oh just coming
out just dropping off my
jacket at the dry cleaners
that's awesome bro i don't think i've
ever legitimately taken anything to the
dry cleaners that means you're a real
you're a real one
yeah
yeah certain stuff that requires dry
cleaning not not in the um
like regular washer and dryer thing
it's another job
is an expensive jacket how much did it
cost
it's probably like
maybe 2 300 something like that
oh
the magic told me not to curse oops
sorry oh
oh did they what are they telling you
tell me if you're not a test friend just
i just got kicked out
[Laughter]
damn you know
i'm kind of surprised that's not the
first time that's happened because
we did push the envelope here a bit he
said if you're not a customer are you
not yet
not welcome
so you didn't you're not using their
services right now
not oh [ __ ] it just dropped off my
jacket oh so but you are a customer so
what's this problem yeah
[ __ ] i don't know
well the good news is
no matter how many dry cleaners we get
kicked out of the good news is that it's
friday
anything interesting going on you want
to report on
nothing nothing in particular
got it got it got it [ __ ] me [ __ ] yeah
all right gabe well you know what i know
you're gonna have a great weekend you're
gonna kick back those white claws right
you're gonna have a good one
and uh you're gonna keep crushing it on
cameo like i know you will all right
yeah baby [ __ ] me [ __ ] yeah
damn white boss baby [ __ ]
did you make a burner account for
watching like uh adult content on
twitter or where do we i don't think so
no no no no
i'm not going to do that right
no you don't want to go into that okay
fair
good
i've i was curious but i understand you
don't want to talk about it yeah just
don't like the post that's all
yeah
people will like go into my likes and
stuff yeah for sure public for sure for
sure
all right gabe you take care you have a
great weekend okay buddy
all right white clock game on cameo baby
[ __ ] baby
sheesh
[Music]
all right
oh poor gabe got kicked out of the dry
cleaner huh sad i kept hearing beeping
in the background i wonder if that was
like the code to let's move on maybe his
nephew
oh for real yeah i didn't hear it i
heard it a couple times
and it was more prevalent when he was
getting kicked out
i figured he was solo today
oh maybe i don't know
no i figured he was doing a selfie
moment right yeah it kind of looked like
it could be yeah
what a legend though man
like claw gabe on cameo
you guys can support his uh
white claw habits
anyway
rice gumby exactly
this [ __ ] built like gumby you
gotta put like uh valenciaga on that
what what yo what was the name of a
gumby's horse
pokey so who would be pokey in his life
can we do faces do you have friends
yeah
but
i mean
i know that came across really mean but
like legitimately who does he hang out
with he used to live with face banks oh
yeah yeah blake lives with the face
clown i think okay yeah he's faced so
yeah maybe maybe
rice grace gum
best friends
i don't know what the [ __ ]
let's see who's our yeah it's blanks for
sure bro are you [ __ ] high right now
no i'm not i'm just tired
so
anyway uh we were saying anyway i love
you ila happy anniversary and you look
great as always oh and by the way just
to show what icon she is you want to
tell about your la fashion show uh
cringe competition i feel bad like um
hating on it publicly why
i don't know
but you want to unpack why
um i went to
early fashion week last night she made a
custom dress
out of teddy fresh
shirts excuse me [ __ ] cool and it's
so sick bro
the outfit was so slapping
and she got all dot up oh belle of
course commented legend oh
icon
so for example i when i was i got the
invite to come to the event so i started
thinking who i could go with and i um
i thought maybe i'll check with bella if
she's going by any chance
and um i messaged her and she's like oh
i i would but i'm gonna be at the paris
fashion week
sorry loser
see you in paris
i was like all right
way better
yeah well it turned out the la one is
actually just like a total cringe fest
like
it's just so
it's just [ __ ] to your fashion i don't
know it wasn't very
it didn't feel like
a very official event to me sorry i
don't i really don't want to
piss anyone off because you want me i'll
tell it from my perspective okay but you
weren't there okay i know what's going
on
i told you though
well it seems like first of all there
was like a huge line to get photos like
everybody was just like uh [ __ ] to your
influencers trying to get photos i
didn't even recognize anyone exactly if
they were influencers well then who the
[ __ ] were they
clue exactly
next
and then you had to get in line to get
to the fashion show and then they're
like they told you like stop
uh it's full for now and they're like
standing there they're like we're just
not letting more people in right now and
um
and it was just two guys like they they
just work there they're just saying what
they were told but um
it became a huge line behind me
and we're like well like do you know for
how long or what
and they just kept saying like
we don't know we just we're just not
letting anyone in right now
it's like
getting it was getting late and you're
just standing there like and then you
bounced
i did yeah
too cool but so
i was excited to see my friend my first
runway show but i didn't get to they
didn't even let your ass in bro wow
maybe we're the [ __ ] there though it was
everybody i don't know where was that
influencer
i mean
kind of right right so we got that
shitty treatment of our own uh deserving
i mean certainly not like emma
chamberlain or bella pork no yeah
we would we they get the right this way
mistreatment
we get the uh this venue is at maximum
capacity
no but you gotta understand it was like
everybody they weren't letting anyone in
i don't understand what was happening
sounds like tanacon yeah it kind of felt
like something like that right like
something was wrong maybe i don't know
but you were saying you know something
about la fashion week because there are
well i just looked it up and apparently
the big four are new york london milan
and paris yeah yeah and then
there's ones in la and some other cities
but those are like it's just the yeah
these nobody gives a [ __ ] like there's
the big door right and then there's this
[ __ ] bro i mean i i knew that but i
thought it could still be fun maybe
yeah i don't think anyone really shows
up here
because like usually it's like celeb
celeb city but yours was just like uh
10k instagram models
honestly as soon as i pulled in
i was
feeling like maybe i should turn around
really black based on what because like
you go into the parking lot and
that's also where people were standing
in line so i could see the line and i
could just see the people and like not
classy it just felt like a weird well
you know what you want real proof that
that event was a trashy [ __ ] affair
it happened in london no
sponsored by
trilogy no i would say that as a joke no
it was one of one of them was the
thriller
no wonder you look going to get in
half cat put the kite wash on you no
way
i mean i'm surprised these [ __ ]
but you know what
um i think her name was lauren
she was a fan of ours who was working
there and she was like helping me and
stuff oh [ __ ] you might get her yeah all
right i don't want anything bad i didn't
say anything bad but i won't say more
but she was great yeah shout out lauren
yeah but anyway capcav
uh it sponsors the [ __ ] la fashion
show and it's perfectly in his style to
sponsor the trashy [ __ ] tear uh
flipped
yeah
yeah in fact when ila was posing for a
photo you know how you do with the
backdrop there was a trailer logo right
there and you were like should i do this
or not and i was like flip off the
triller logo dude make a scene but yeah
i only saw you say that after would you
have done it after the fact i maybe
she would have been [ __ ] up lift it
off
like slip flip
flipped it off yeah
yeah so
anyway guys let's get into the show you
know anyway lesson wise um whenever i'm
like why do i not why do i never do
anything and always just stay at home it
was like probably for a good reason like
ever well you know what i thought it was
nice though you got to make the dress
you've got to go out even though you had
to basically do 180
right
something redeeming maybe maybe yeah
okay all right thank you
yeah so eli we had a big plan today to
unveil our new
my new uh
identity i guess alter ego
ethel cline
so that we could dominate the wikifeet
women's board
but
they put like a hold on our account
they take 48 hours now to verify
accounts like they have locked this
website
so i just want to say to everyone that
was expecting ethel klein's triumphant
uh
triumphant to splash onto the scene
we're waiting for our account to be
verified what if did we make the account
here in the building
you think they ip checked it no but that
was at my account when we got banned
yeah our wikiworld was over there was at
my house okay yeah abe and i both
tried to make an account yeah i'm
checking my email again i don't see any
approval
i didn't use my h3 account either wait
you guys tried to make me either what's
your credentials
what do you mean we tried a few times
because no but don't you have to have
like a legit imdb page and stuff no just
to make an account you have to put an
email and a username yeah you don't even
let users sign up we like and i have an
imdb then i'll have you know
what the [ __ ] are your credits
we all do yeah
not
you look good on the uh on that gender
swap yeah
[Music]
what's going on i guess it's war sounds
okay the feet being chopped up
ninja
wow okay well when when we get clearance
you know i'm gonna
make a splash
you know in response to kim kardashian
calling me calling me out
because you discovered wiki feet
yeah yeah
uh also
um you know what
ela's here and i feel like we have to
address this together
yeah we've endured bullying
we've endured shame
for the name we picked for the baby
and by the way this is a tweet from this
year someone said how can you look at
newborn baby and then i am at bruce i
don't get it what i just don't
understand okay first of all six
thousand almost on the subreddit like
guys come on now there's a lot of things
out there it wasn't yet a hundred
percent ethan wasn't supposed to say it
we're backing out it wasn't 500
no i i still don't get i don't know it
makes me wonder if it's because i'm not
from here i'm prepared
what does that mean i don't know
but look at look at this i don't know
what the [ __ ] wrong with these people
i like bruce there's no i've only
unknown every bruce that i know of is
awesome i've never met a bruce in real
life
why joker sound
bruce willis bruce willis
bruce lee bruce wayne
springsteen
good people
any other uh bruces we should know
one of the guys from kids in the halls
named bruce bruce
but i guess people were saying it just
reminds them of like a dad
someone's dad
okay fine but like all right so we're
not we're so we're out on bruce
congratulations actually this morning
saw some bruce lander on uh
timeline yeah no kidding unrelated to us
yeah they were saying sometimes i think
about the fact that bruce springsteen's
name is bruce and i'm like what the [ __ ]
what it was like a tweet something like
that what's wrong with that
i don't know the dude what's the problem
he's an iconic name he's bruce [ __ ]
springsteen
who in here hates it because some
somebody here must hate it based on the
numbers right well my my parents came
out and like when we said we're yeah
everybody was my parents were like yeah
we hate that name we [ __ ] hate that
name
everybody in the family we're like so it
turns out nobody likes the name and
they're like
but we [ __ ] hate that name
i trust in your guys opinion though i
mean because at first when you guys
first announced
theodore's name on the show i was like i
thought that's like an old school name
but now i think it's adorable like i
think that's perfect like
so i don't know thank you for trusting
me because i know
that's how i like i have that 4d
intuition on the name right and in a few
years time
bruce is going to be a banging name
right now there's nobody because it's
walking around it's like unusual exactly
it's unusual it's powerful you know
everybody wants oliver
i know
and and we told the family and they were
all like oh we love oliver but i feel
like it's
first of all it's already so common
and we know oliver is in our life and
it's the third most common what the [ __ ]
which is not
it's not a bad thing but it's like
forever related to the person you know
and by the way i've i'll be damned from
my name my son after that punk ass
he's so [ __ ] so here's
blanks
and uh gumby rice
rice gumby
i think i think it's a cute name um yeah
yeah i really i don't know
i'm fine with it too i'm not sure why
there's so many things
maybe we should stick with bruce because
through it all you know what also rust
trust i'm telling you in five ten years
people are gonna understand
that this name
is powerful the thing is the cutest
thing is that theodore already calls him
bruce mm-hmm
so it's like that's the that's the part
that i'm like well
tito is already like yeah he's already
falling in bruce
i think it has to be bruce and i'm sorry
but [ __ ] you all
and you're gonna find it you're gonna
see we're still getting right i'm
keeping a list of like the best names so
far i have a short list we'll see are
you hiding it from ethan
no he knows
[Laughter]
but i i i think you know what you got to
trust the process
it's a special everybody's demanding a
poll
[ __ ] you ain't gonna vote i
think we already got the vote from you
guys how about you vote on your you know
what i'm saying yeah what do you want to
vote on if uh what's what's the vote on
next if me and eli should stay together
or not yeah divorce questions yeah
that's no
you look at the board i think we pretty
much got the majority of um yeah enough
was said we got the report we don't need
any more from you guys
and i bet if we did a poll people would
vote to keep the name after hearing
that but i know how you all feel yeah
now my parents got to live with the fact
that they said they hated the [ __ ]
name
you left me in the black hole and i'm
gonna tell that kid when he's 10 years
old grandma grandpa said they hate your
[ __ ] name
[Laughter]
yeah so anyway
oh you want to try so we did the squid
games last week
by the way
victor royale this week and yeah ethan
of this week ethan uh that was a fair
and square win that was not rigged he uh
he's pretty amazing that
it worked out well yeah because we were
thinking about it when we were planning
it we're like it would suck if ethan got
eliminated early um so like maybe we
should rig the first few games or
something like no that was
nope we gotta do it authentically no
rigging and uh
he went the distance man
yeah i don't know if we should recap it
because it was pretty interesting
well you needed some wins because i
always on frenemies it was like oh i was
listening always patricia true
well anyway if you want to try well like
carry on
basically i gotta say the cookie thing
oh my god
did you just break it no it was a clean
break it was a clean break that's what
i'm saying the cookie thing is so much
easier in life than they make it look
like on the shelf really like the show
that made it look like
it's so [ __ ] easy well the steaks are
so high yeah
they're gonna die
[Music]
but they i don't think as many oh you're
going to try to lick the back straight
up the gate
is that not what we're supposed to do
now use the pin to carve it out so
that's what we're looking for
so zach was the one who
slipped me that lighter and he was like
oh in the show just to be a secret dan
well i sold you out
who else
who else has a jack daniels zippo
lighter yeah his building is
entertaining secret about that
badass i own it i could put dude on the
desk
but yeah so i i heated up that needle
and i did it and i got to tell you it
was actually ridiculously effective
and
i stopped
using it that way because i i kind of
felt bad i was like it was cheating i
mean by the way it's definitely cheating
because it just it literally just melts
through the cookie i could have just
gone
oh [ __ ] are you dead
get the paintball gun let me see
a little corner came off you're on the
wrong street cause
we all took a hit from a paintball so
you gotta take this
okay you ready you're gonna get a bug
assaulted all right
death
i don't know by the way my my mark is
it's still there man this [ __ ] hurt oh
let me see wait the paintball yeah
should i send the picture there
i never got shot because i [ __ ] won
true damn it sucks that would've been
fun
i was ready
i'm ready to take a hit so crunchy
so anyway
um
new favorite tick-tocker
identified
this guy's super popular too he just hit
3 million
and he's letting us know
harry is thanking everyone for three
million
it sucks we can't listen to music but
it's like uh maybe
yeah and then he
[Laughter]
but what he does is um
he just eats food and then does slaps
that dance here's 1.7 million views oh
wait that's the thank you
here he is eating a
some nacho cheese
hit that chip and then you know it slaps
bro
hit it
hit it
hit it
that's it
that's his whole thing is his trademark
move dude he invented a dance move
that's just so fire
that's crazy
yeah here let's see
here he is eating a salad hitting that
hard bro little ranch dressing
play this part when he dances at bring
it up
[Music]
all right turn it down
there's actually interesting details
here he spills the ranch and then he
puts it in the ranch kind of interesting
to dissect a little bit there
took a big ass by the ranch straight to
the yeah
look at the first comment
man yeah that was just a big old getting
some uh pushback from the chat right now
he did not invent that dance apparently
oh wait who's the inventor
i don't know all right well you didn't
invent the dance
i mean
i mean
what great mind could think of such an
original this one has 35 million views
whoa
yeah
i mean
jesus this bomb is [ __ ] dude but you
know what the man eats his broccoli okay
so yeah don't hate i mean even if
that's pretty epic tick tock
yeah i like this is the kind of [ __ ] i
live for on tick tock i wish i saw stuff
like that i don't take talk
i'm too basic i guess it just shows me
like
the typical dancing people i mean this
guy's mainstream so i mean this has 43
million views
look at this
look at all that butter boy let's go
that looks hot too you know what it
slaps though hit it
[Laughter]
you like this [ __ ]
well yeah i gotta say butter on corn is
so unnecessary
if you click the uh i'm revoking your
citizenship no i don't care about the
court if you click the sound will it
maybe show you so original let's see the
chat is saying let's get proper
attributions here obviously
chad is saying the dance from someone
with down syndrome oh that's really a
lovely young man with down syndrome did
it first i see sophie did
that's amazing
well we got to give uh praise to the
original yeah to the og
here i'll check the sound
oh man this butter this popcorn won't
actually trip me out i'm not going to
lie look at all that butter
wait no no no no no more music
this one i don't quite get i'll be
honest this one's a little artistic oh
it's a different one
[ __ ]
here here's the butter one look at all
that butter damn dude come on now
and you know there's just soup that's
just soup on the bottom of that
but okay it slaps
well can someone check for me because
i'm not logged in i'm scrolling through
the sound i clicked on the sound i'm
just scrolling and i'm just seeing him a
lot and then just some random people
i don't know shout out to whoever i
think i found the original oh okay thank
you thank you thank you
i sent it
shout out to his [ __ ] family man wait
is this it
mean love sent the same guy we just sent
different videos okay
so here's the original
oh i have seen this guy oh this guy
invented it
according to this is this this is just a
meme
[Music]
he definitely hits it with stink
let me see what he's up to
um
i guess he's not riding the meme like
the other guy though you know
i got to make a few of those i feel like
i think that that meme becomes me well
[Music]
eating lots of cheese and
dancing
uh yeah stan
uh
this is just a beer
okay let's hit it let's take a jerk
after this
damn whoa
dan
let's talk about why you said that
i could not say that i was like sound
bite you said i can jerk off sound i can
jerk off to this zach has this program
that allows him to why you thought that
was appropriate to say right now little
snippets of audio and play them back on
demand feel better than what he has done
feel my pain
that was so he has deceived you all he's
deceived you all i have no evidence
against what happened
here he's out in the wild this is the
last one but he's out in the wild
whoa
careful man this one has a lot of views
too oh [ __ ] he's on a wrong careful
hurt yourself he's got a nice little bop
yeah he's really bouncing he's bouncing
that's a very good bomb right there
that's my man right there
top comment it's the bridge from
fortnite
like the pewdiepie pewdiepie me oh wait
that's what i was thinking too but that
was like fortnite that was probably yeah
okay never mind so introducing our
uh youtube superstar
big congrats also we revisiting r
kelly's do you have your passports
um can you play it while we read these
comments
we noticed that the comments were
hilarious on the video
especially now
i got it i got it it's hard not to just
sing it
this is the most beautiful song about
human trafficking i've ever heard
i don't and there's not many of them but
you know
this needs to be the intro for 90 day
fiance oh my god have your passports did
you get your shots i about died when the
backup singers joined in america america
to america
they literally were hurt that means they
rehearsed this [ __ ] boy i love this song
i think it's fully improvised
i really do
i think they're just really talented you
do i think this whole thing was just how
did they hide in the back of the hangers
because they're just they're good they
are they're good and they've just
rehearsed and played together how would
they know that there was two americas
well they because they just they feel
the vibe you got it you all flow with me
i think you're so right and that's
my mind is blown
now was just doing his thing they just
i
right
repeated that
on the road my dude
i think he rehearsed this and he did it
at every show
well you do have a point with who he is
yeah that might be something that you
maybe started like you're saying yeah
right did you you know i think dan is
right because we haven't seen any other
videos of him doing it yeah it just
seemed like it was old
i mean he did a tour how many videos are
there out there with how big of a meme
it is
they were jamming you feel like you're
jamming you agree zach that it seems
like it's just a jam absolute show on
the road my dudes i feel like recruiting
i don't know i feel like as soon as dan
said it it clicked in my head that
that's what happened well we need to
analyze it a little more then turn it up
have we seen the beginning of the clip
before
of course yeah yeah yeah how does he
introduce it well here let me pull it up
um our it's such a masterpiece that's
beautiful yeah
it's like they said it's the most
beautiful song about human trafficking i
mean it's gorgeous it's stunning i mean
r kelly do you have your passports
i wonder if our kelly's seen this clip
like now that
he's he's like [ __ ] i shouldn't have
done that
i gave the game away
this was the record
so wait here's a full seven minute clip
leading up to it okay let's see this is
very interesting wait my girl here i'm
in ethiopia this might just be a
different no no no no no no
it looks like the same thing
you have your passport this has got to
be it it's it
yeah oh this is baby yeah whoa i'm
feeling it they're jamming they're just
jamming yeah i swear
no no no no
first of all jamming i'm sorry but let's
settle down for a second
let's settle down for a minute
i got a problem we got a problem turn it
up dan come on now okay
i love this pulse i think i'm gonna
pause the best before i got on the hang
on
okay we gotta listen i know i'm back it
up hang on r kelly the best thing about
this [ __ ] song is that it never gets
claimed
ever
this is we should make this our theme
song who's going to sue us are kelly
from jail
he needs the money
yeah well that [ __ ] i mean
you got to pay a lawyer first
this is a longer version i didn't know
that more before
okay well here here we go this is
actually a big deal i think
okay is this improvised
the day before i got on the plane to
come out here
me and my girl broke up oh [ __ ] poor rob
the one that got away
i didn't think he let him get away
[Music]
he's the one that ran
yeah her parents found her yeah
the day before i came here
the girl locked in my dungeon was able
to escape
i left the spoon downstairs and she
managed to claw through the brick
[Laughter]
chip away chisel away
uh
dude there's no dude i'm sorry but even
when you improvise there is you know
kind of where you're going with it you
the beat is not just invented on the
spot it's
pretty simple i mean it's a simple chord
progression yeah
i'm telling you this is a show they take
on the road you don't [ __ ] they're
not this isn't fish bro you don't think
it's like filler music they're not just
like
what like filler music yeah they're just
yeah but even the filler music i'm sure
they know yeah i'm sure the filler
it sounds to me it sounds like you
improv on top of the already written
filler exactly yeah
let's let's listen shall we
i refuse to believe
yo
[Music]
wow he said that back then
and it was over something really really
silly
something like i was making her eyes
i was making her ask for permission to
go to the bathroom like she didn't call
me daddy she didn't call me daddy and i
slapped that [ __ ] as hard as i could
sorry
that's
but it is it is what it is we broke up
and here i am
[Music]
is that anybody out there single
yeah
that broke up with a man and they
looking for somebody else you think this
is written this is totally this is
totally a problem
come on this is improvised
is there anybody out there
who's broken up and looking for a man
right now
okay
america
do you think it would be um do you think
he would be in prison now if it wasn't
for that documentary surviving r kelly
yeah i think it was all part of the same
[ __ ] going i don't know because i was
thinking that documentary was really
powerful
what was the document before he got
arrested or i guess i don't remember
that yeah
maybe it was
that [ __ ] was disturbing bro the girls
would go into the house where he used to
keep them and they'd be like this room
i can't even talk about this room there
was one room in particular where they're
like
i can't even tell you what happened in
this room and they're like i just want
to i was like mother
dude
the documentary was in january of 2019
and the first arrest was july of 2019.
okay
wow
i got it well in relation to this crime
at least
maybe it did eh
fantastic good for them britney wasn't
freed until everybody made a lot of
noise that's for sure yeah
okay
i mean kind of the same thing happened
with cosby
that dude
yeah
straight up
no munching she's like the he was like
the mrs pop mrs pot
poppins of
assaulting women
a spoonful of sugar
he's free now
yeah whatever you do don't have drinks
with bill cosby if he invites you
anyway
yeah
you gotta be
[Music]
this is my vaccination card
i mean
[Music]
now i would like to get to know you and
talk to you
have a drink or something dude this is
like hypnosis you know somebody said i
wonder if this concert video was
presented as everything at the end
dude i had that exact same thing
oh my god exhibit uh 24 for your honor
r kelly uh recruiting people for sexual
trafficking by the way massive likes on
this is from 10 years ago i wonder if
people know
yeah i mean okay but the likes i think
they're liking it just because it's they
find it humorous well i don't know can i
be old
no
i feel like if you don't know the
background you can kind of be like it's
funny
all the comments from two years ago
which i think is when we first started
talking about it
i'm looking for something from like 10
years ago but okay
at the end of the conversation i'm gonna
want you to come back to america with me
[Applause]
i come out here to see you
in ethiopia
but it's so hard to get back and forth
so hard to get back before problem
how am i gonna get you
from ethiopia
to america
this is the craziest [ __ ] i've ever seen
on stage
that's this is it's getting weird now
yo
he's setting up the song he's setting it
up let me think do you have your past
maybe he just already has it in his head
so she has it in his head he's like
working towards something you think he's
like
i mean he is a brilliant like yeah i
think you're underestimating i mean
he's a monster obviously but the guy is
extremely talented musician i think he's
just he's just doing his thing when it
comes to like r b stuff like james brown
was in tory for this too like his band
had to be on it know it split second
yeah or changing something that's it
yeah yeah well what are you trying to
tell me that mozart wrote his uh sixth
symphony uh just on stage improvised no
noted r d artist mozart
this is [ __ ] mozart bro
this is a masterpiece it's a masterpiece
if it wasn't for the content
this would be
legendary music
[Music]
he's stinking so hard how are we going
to get these girls i recognize this shot
i got it over to him do you have your
passport
did you get your shots
girl would you like to come back with
rob to america
[Music]
oh he's got it america
dude there's no way this is improvised
this is a show he takes on the road
[Music]
girl would you like to come back
this i cannot watch this video enough
time i know
it's like it's like a problem
it is
i actually listen to this on my playlist
like i'll be like kendrick
the beatle
and then r kelly comes on and i get
excited i'm like
did you get your shots
girl would you like to come back i only
pop out to that [ __ ] would you like to
come back with rob to america
it's powerful music
people want to pull
i think we can do a poll on this one
yeah
if it's if it's improvised or not yeah
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
damn
take my dude i'm coming with her i don't
care
[Music]
let's see how he ends it because this
could be informative as well
[Music]
dude those girls they're basically
throwing passports on stage at this
point
here's my vaccination card here's my
passport
all right i just created the poll he's
like i'm not kidding he's like yeah he's
ready to take some girls backstage he's
he's like an army recruiter he's like
all right i'm gonna send my crew this
round
tell them your name tell them your age
send a photo
this is an actual r kelly song yeah
i can already tell
but also just for claim like yeah yeah
but that one was rehearsed
yeah but listen like he's missing notes
his heart's not in this one
like his first i'm just telling you like
the passion was all in the last song
because
[Music]
uh so far it's uh
it's about two-thirds of the audience
saying it's improvised what the [ __ ] do
you guys know about music
[Laughter]
dude that's the song that he they're
saying
we need a third option he's a monster
and we don't care no come on that's not
an option i mean that goes without you
yeah that's implied in every response
that's the default response that's both
yeah yeah
yeah
in the album of comments there's one
point where it says the manager is
watching this happen and freaking out
oh
it's just me but it's pretty funny he
got me wanting to come to america and
already live here
i like to imagine the guy standing there
at 46
seconds his manager stunned and
horrified by his bizarre and totally
unplanned recruitment song completely
helpless as everything goes to [ __ ]
this guy here yep
he's like oh [ __ ] here he goes again
this is the epitome of using your
god-given talent for evil yeah yeah
damn this [ __ ] is so catchy i'm already
in america but i might fly to ethiopia
just get my shots and get human traffic
back here with rob
r kelly about to make a huge comeback
this year this is the official song for
getting vaccinated
yeah
i love this song man
uh we've got to do our break yeah i play
it right next to uh there's a little
known song by michael jackson called
crawling to my bed little kid so that's
another one that's just
it's really good but it's so wrong
you heard that one maybe
[Music]
you gotta take the ab right
we'll be right back
it's live
there's no let's be right back all right
let's go hello fresh
hello fresh
hit
that fresh ingredients this is america's
number one meal kit oh damn this is
what's up
whoa whoa discord right dan a fupa
trooper yo
that looks great they felt baptized
always struggling with uh abe's burrito
that kind of looks like my burrito it
kind of looks like not at all
makes me want to eat did you ever see uh
abey's burrito ela i did okay
so iconic
very clean yeah go down let's let's
let's browse
well
i wanted to use this
oh you want to save it yeah
all right what is hello fresh they send
you pre-measured ingredients with
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door this way
you're going to skip the grocery store
and they're going to make cook cooking
at home easy fun affordable delicious
nutritious if you've never cooked before
this is a great way to get in because
basically they send you all the perfect
ingredients fresh the best you can get
they tell you exactly what to do you're
going to learn a lot you're going to
learn how to cook and the food is always
going to be delicious that's what we
love you're going to get better value
hello fresh is over 30 cheaper than
shopping at grocery stores with
pre-portioned ingredients that ensure
you won't spend money on excess food
that ends up in the trash you don't even
have to think about it dude no brainer
hellofresh offers the flexibility you
need to easily customize your order on
the app within minutes easily change
your delivery day food preference and
plant size or skip a week whenever you
need
to do so
obviously we all use and love hello
fresh i mean what are these these are uh
uh
enchilada
little enchilada action oh chelata
damn what's up
big connect
i'm about to take i'm about to give
those enchiladas their shots and
passwords take them over
anyway guys go to hellofresh.com after
dark 14 and use code after dark 14 for
up to 14 free meals including free
shipping that's 14 free meals
pretty epic come on
uh that's hellofresh.com after dark
14 and use code after dark 14 for 14
free meals thank you thank you guys to
america's number one meal kit hello
fresh
[Music]
hmm
can you play rob is it would you can you
play uh
uh uh did you get your shots did you get
your passports while i read it you think
that's inappropriate
um
come on it's cracking they're cool
did you get your shots hey guys
thank you to kraken i'll make this one
up to dan
let's try it kraken's cool let's just
see how it plays well just why
why yeah why it's funny i think we
shouldn't
i just feel like it's going to be weird
because there's words in this right
yeah it's horribly inappropriate yeah
right right
[Laughter]
the instrumental is beautiful
and it's royalty-free i don't even know
what what do you want me to say
listen to them
all right let's just do the kraken it's
funny
we've spent 30 minutes on it already too
this episode
got no problems paying another 30.
hey guys thank you to kraken so much we
love the kraken hey guys if you're
interested in investing in crypto
currencies but aren't sure where to get
started check out the kraken app with
kraken you can buy and sell over 50 the
most popular cryptos like bitcoin
dogecoin and ethereum on the go
twenty-four
seven it's superior it's super easy to
get started just download the app create
your account and you're gonna be
investing in minutes one of the coolest
things about buying crypto through the
kraken app or online with kraken is that
uh you don't need a lot of money to try
it out so even if bitcoin is trading at
like 40 000
you can get started and buy a little bit
of bitcoin for as little as 10 bucks
on the cr on kraken just to get your
feet wet and see if it's something you
like something you're interested you can
track the highs and lows see what you
know what i'm saying it's a fun way to
just get started low risk
low barrier of entry find out for
yourself why kraken has been one of the
highest rated places to buy crypto for
the last 10 years kraken
one most trusted
longest ones in the game
friend of the show so please support uh
consider supporting kraken visit
kraken.com after dark now to learn more
or search for kraken in the app store
thank you to kraken love you
this sounds like jam too it is
um
important update i just glanced at my
phone
and i had an email
and i recognized the name you remember
the email that i read out on the show of
somebody brutally roasting my eyebrows
oh
yeah one of my favorite segments
well that same person just said it warms
my heart that you took my suggestion
seriously looking good
did you did you do anything here i
stopped shaving it like i said
wait wait wait i've been i've been
plucking in the middle like everybody
told me to okay so so
there was
so you were shaving
yeah i was just using the razor to like
just ch
like they had left a a very impassioned
company it was a brutal like backhanded
compliment basically they were like oh
you're you're my favorite person on the
show you're so handsome except your
eyebrows ruin everything
well there you go i mean looking good
yeah how do you feel now that you're
plucking the eyebrow instead of shaving
it hurts to do that oh you get used to
that it hurts
but
every time i'm like the socks it looks
fire
i hope dan is going to be able to
actually it gives you appreciation for
the for what the ladies oh absolutely
yeah i know on the reg
mad respect to all the pluckers out
there people love your eyes dan you got
to take care of your your eyebrows oh my
god
good eyebrow game though for sure yeah
but yeah so they said they actually said
uh i'm watching the show right now rub
your brows if you want to give me a
secret shoot well i gave you a public
shout out so there you go dan has been
fantastic do we know anything about this
person
no it's just like an anonymous a woman
or a man or uh
their name is i won't say it but it's
not an actual name it's like a okay
internet handle sound is a completely
random email yeah it's just like a cold
email
well
miracles do happen sometimes you can
change the world that's right sometimes
an email can change the world that's
true
man we got we got so much content here
um we did a segment ela i don't know if
you saw it it was
there was been all these memes this the
subreddit completely turned on me and
they'd be like ethan's the type of guy
too
you saw that i was wondering why is it
happening because they hate me
no there was just one that we saw that
was really funny and we read it on the
show and then that just started like a
flood of them
yeah well anyway it turned into this
whole thing where everyone was like
ethan the type of guy and i was like
i've literally never done that in my
life i refute that entirely
but now we have a ethan type of guy in
ila type of
lady
dan we have one for everybody so
this one shows everything should i click
them individually or just i just figured
it would be too much clicking so i just
okay screenshotted
even the type of guy to spray cologne in
the air and shimmy through the mitt
nope that is my favorite one
i'm not that guy i've never done that
i'm not that guy
i don't wear cologne no yeah but i just
see you like
yeah but well well i guess i could like
in that situation if i try to imagine
you i could see that maybe like spray
sunscreen
you just walk right through
no sunscreen needs to be applied evenly
and directly to the skin right
even the type of guy who pushes his
plate away after eating saying take this
away from me only to take a few more
nibbles and uh on remaining food once
it's pushed away
that's me yeah
nailed me for that one
[Laughter]
ethan type of guy to slap a 20 pound bag
of dog food
as he walks by in the store
interesting
so specific very specific this guy is
the one who does that like who would
write that
i do feel like i would do that
i do feel like i am that kind of guy
even the type of guy to lift one of his
legs up behind him while kissing a girl
that's cold
you're not that guy i'm not that guy
thank you
oh dear
yeah well you guys got a good laugh at
my expense so here's one's for all you
guys i think you're so funny yep yep
what'd you send me
i don't know at this time stamp when i
read that first one about you walking
through the cologne i imagine you
walking like you did in the last episode
through the egg race
well i'm wait
[Laughter]
honestly yeah well you all should take a
note because my i dominated that egg you
were as fast as [ __ ] boy
did you watch this
[Music]
yeah i destroyed this
[Laughter]
well let's start
let's start with you then a b
wise guy
a b
the type of guy to say no sweat but
proceed to sweat
i'll agree with that one i'll take that
a be the type of guy to rescue a kitten
from a tree but only as soon as someone
notices it and starts recording then
asks did you get that
wow
that's cold i'll have to accept that
i'll do it either way but if someone's
recording then that's a bonus bonus
exactly yeah yeah well you did do that
but with a baby right i don't know if
that counts if he actually orchestrated
the whole accident
maybe the type of guy to orchestrate a
family crashing on the freeway
in the car igniting
yes
amy the type of guy to check every
single reblogged tag
of his viral tumbler post yeah that one
really guy
i'm not as familiar with tumblr but
probably
so you accept it all for the most part
hit me baby because for me i was uh-uh
i'll switch him back
i guess they nailed you
dan there's a lot for dan people have
thoughts on dan
i have thoughts on these people's
thoughts
let's see
dan the type of guy to eat pizza with
knife and fork yep you've got boned a
thousand likes damn that type of dude
you just got owned
that pizza was the chicago deep dish
pizza that we ordered the other day
how the [ __ ] you supposed to eat that
without the pork
[Music]
you didn't go back did it get all over
the place because no dude mine was
literally falling apart like it was just
goo yeah it'd be like eating lasagna by
hand hey dude here's you eating pizza
with knife and four
a lot of people say chicago pizza isn't
pizza he has no pizza oh my god
this whole debate over me yeah a lot of
people say that it's not pizza yeah
ask any new yorkers okay so it's a pie
right what is it
you eat pie with a fork
it's i love pizza okay well then a lot i
mean it got a thousand points dan i mean
those people are wrong what's your take
on this i mean look at this
i'm thorn you didn't see the pizza it
was a mess it was a mess
pull up me eating it pull up me eating
it you're going to see it was very
master at work
it was difficult to eat without a fork
at night did you eat it with a pork
knife it was hard you had to see thank
you
i'm pulling it up i served it to all of
you guys with a knife and fork so it
might be my fault but
ethan chose not to use it so it's of
course what am i psychotic i got in the
car and my wife's like what's wrong with
you
i just have pizza sauce all over
she's never asked me that out of
everything
just straight up what's wrong with you
people saying it's it's a casserole not
a pizza yeah ela actually asked me that
on a nightly basis so i'm fairly easy
i just get in bed and she looks at me
and she goes what's wrong with you
when i say i don't know honey
i love you the way that you are
this apparently is me denying that i'm
not that guy
what
i'm not that guy i'm not
my god i hate this
i'm not that guy pal that was cursed
yeah that is actually cursed i hate that
can i show you another cursed image i
saw on the subreddit you're gonna hate
it and i hate it yeah you do
i [ __ ] hate it bro i hate it more hey
there's a really nice drawing of sam on
here
oh yeah i saw that yeah we look we saw
that this morning nice it's lovely
it's really nice
um it's the one of ela as this [ __ ] i
hate why why
wait it had more there's another one
right yeah there was more one with more
votes
i hate this guy
wait
wait we're using the same image i didn't
even realize i don't know what's going
on here and i don't think i want it to
stop wait you want this they want this
they want us to keep using the same
image
i'm confused by it it works for
pewdiepie right it works for everybody
does it because it's stupid you gotta
take up some of it
oh damn oh my god are you looking for
that cursed image of you yeah my dad it
says
i sent it
that one's really funny it's in this
card
this is freaking me out with my dad
smash that like button
oh
why are you picturing a quick edit there
nice
yeah here it is here it is
every time he hit she turned into this
dude okay with peace and love
i was telling the crew that i would be
down to start banning this kind of post
really yeah
i ban it too
yes i hate it but it always looks like
the same guy and i hate him i hate this
guy
dude i'm freaking scared
that's cursed as [ __ ] i hate it anyway
and it's like they never go away
you found the post of me eating the
pizza yeah i sent it okay it's right
above the so you want to see a master at
work here like
is this the somebody come on now oh
that's not the real stuff come on
whatever
mine was not that like together
it really wasn't can we go to the cheese
zone real quick enter
the jew zone
you know i'm sorry
i'm sorry you weren't supposed to see
this god is this the veggie one roll it
why are you guys thinking there's a lot
of veggies you weren't supposed to see
this
because there we are what kind of
content is that
there was a whole debate about
if ethan liked pie or not and then we
were like pizza pie and he was like
pizza is not pie and then we started
talking about chicago pizza which is
very pie-like and he's like i've never
had chicago pizza before and then all of
the chat was like
oh you gotta you gotta try it you gotta
try this place you gotta try that place
so we found a place nearby ordered some
brought it we all tried chicago pizza
the first time i gotta say i was sold
yeah it was good i feel like this was a
whole conspiracy so ethan could get
pizza i feel like i knew he was doing
that that's exactly what he had chicago
people before no i haven't i haven't
actually you probably did and the god
you probably did hand the card i never
had a piece it really is very
but it was never like that it was just
like
we looked up like chicago pizza and i
remember we went all the way down to
like
by the statue of liberty like super down
in
wall street right and the it's just like
thick ass crust
you remember
yeah
this was a pie real chicago pizza the
crust isn't thick it's still relatively
thin but then the toppings are like this
thick it's like insane which is why it's
like a pie mm-hmm it's great it's like a
pie crust with a bunch you want to order
stuff on it absolutely not
wait what's up instagram facebook's down
again
again no holy [ __ ] eat [ __ ] mark
zuckerberg you [ __ ] i literally just got
a notification when i went to the
bathroom telling me
apologizing for being down earlier this
week so wait let me do a test here on
our group chat let's see test
i said it went through did you guys see
it
oh nice one love
my instagram isn't loading though
instagram okay oh mine won't load but i
actually i saw the notification
i just i'd like when it's down because i
just want i just want pain to come to
facebook mark zuckerberg
i guess i did something to piss off the
instagram
is facebook
yeah right now but it was down like
literally two seconds ago it's so
awesome dude
[ __ ] love it
i wish nothing but the worst for them
here is the ultimate curse podcast
god
this is us in the alternate universe i'm
not going to look at it i'm looking away
okay i don't want to i don't want to
trigger you
what's his name duty
his name is doody
dude
the [ __ ] is walking around the
israel named dudu
it is a name i know dudu
so anyway back to dan's the type of guy
dan's the type of guy to have a
toothbrush in this condition before
sugar hell no four
sure no
zero percent oh really yeah no it's
disgusting
[Laughter]
for sure all right dan's the type of guy
to take a girl on a date to whole foods
hate whole foods
overpriced terrible food
dan really doesn't like these
i'm telling you these people do not know
me oh really yeah
i showed it i showed it to ali last
night and she was like these are none of
these make sense i just i know someone
that i just took a date
dan's the type of guy to get on social
media just to talk about how much he
hates it
i never go on social media i post like
once every two months wait but you kind
of did that with mr verified so it kind
of fits you know
interesting was that on social media
well is youtube social media it was
layers of social media it's the best see
it's so much more fun when i'm doing it
and dan's getting better yeah
this one is great uh dan is the type of
guy
who says that first star wars movie
actually was fourth in chronological
order
for the first one
so
i don't acknowledge the existence of the
prequels those movies are terrible so
that statement doesn't make any sense
either
wow
it sounded very accurate
whatever you just never exactly dan
doesn't like sand
it's coarse yeah dan's the type of guy
to respond actually when you say
tomatoes one of your favorite veggies
would never say that because i know
technically tomatoes are fruit but
they're not they're veggies they have
veggie energy i'm sorry i'll never back
down from that tomatoes are a vegetable
thank you i don't even think this but
just to play devil's advocate for a
second oh my god
i mean that phrase could have saved my
life
yeah
i learned
something you survived i'm playing yeah
you survived i hate when people say it's
a vegetable actually
you hate when people say it's a
vegetable yeah dan just said that yeah
right no it's a fruit oh i mean you're
with me yes i'm with you i mean
everybody i know scientifically it's
technically a fruit i don't care it's a
vegetable it has vegetable energy eat it
like a fruit yes some people crazy i
mean yeah they're psychotic psychopaths
yo ian you gotta hit hard bro these are
highly upvoted
and the type of guy who continues to
actively listen to you while everyone
else stops paying attention that's a
compliment i think yeah
brutal takedown i appreciate that [ __ ]
also to wait for you to tie your shoes
while everyone else keeps walking
wow these are nice why didn't anyone do
that i have to tell ian the same thing
like three times in a row sometimes
because he's so spaced out that one is
not true
you're the exact same
you're so not
[Laughter]
is the type of guy that asks if every
company outing is optional or mandatory
[Laughter]
going out is hard sometimes
that is true [ __ ] right there
uh ab you ready oh i did yours
maybe the type of guy to want me to do
is again
[Laughter]
just kidding
um
zach you have quite a few there's a lot
on there we pinned zach
zach the type of guy to see a girl in a
band t and make her name three of their
songs bet your ass
[ __ ]
like do you i don't know you said that
you're out yeah
no yeah that's that's it
that's good
zach the type of guy to keep go to a
karaoke bar and take it really seriously
i'm still praying for karaoke with the
clients man
wow so far
zach the type of guy to [ __ ] on
someone's lawn and take a photo of it
and say that they're proud of it to this
day i'm just kidding i made that one up
well actually i was gonna say that
literally
yeah
still proud
zach the type of guy to eat out a girl's
sweaty ass on a hike
[Music]
yeah okay the validity to that
zach the type of guy to smell his own
fart and say everybody loves their own
brand i said that last night
i've heard zach say that before
[Laughter]
zach's the type of guy to tell you he
knows authentic italian cuisine in
chicago then brings you to olive garden
actually bj's
wait who was it that suggested bj yeah
it was zach just the other day looking
for authentic chicago
and i was like oh what is bj's and then
i look up and it's like oh the [ __ ]
chain
that got misconstrued if i may say so
really yeah i was suggesting a place in
chicago called gino's but like there was
in the conversation what could we get
you said i said in california
because we were looking for a place how
did that get misconstrued you literally
recommended we get pizza from b he was
making a joke on how we can't get any
authentic pizza out here oh so it wasn't
a serious suggestion no no i got you
sick thank you ap no prom baby
so far these are all true i mean
attack the type of guy to bring out his
acoustic guitar and sing wonder while at
a bonfire nah that i wouldn't do
that you would sing something you'd
think something else yeah yeah yeah but
i wouldn't do wonder wall okay what
would you do
stairway now to to
i call people out for that [ __ ]
oh god
probably like i don't know to let people
live their lives sweet virginia by the
stone did you play wonderwall on the
guitar just like a week ago
no
i think you did
no i did not
i kind of feel like when you were tuning
my guitars out yeah you did
i played roundabout
[Music]
that's the type of guy to say two in the
pink one the stink the shocker baby oh
my god there was one really good one
that we didn't add it said zach's the
type of guy that whenever a girl texts
i'm in the shower he responds without me
[Laughter]
i don't know what they're talking about
thank you for life my dudes
oh yeah
for life
and then olivia got one
[Music]
olivia this is very did you read this
one olivia
i did it was very very complimentary
olivia the type of gal to make sure
the drunk friends get home okay oh we
love that
i have one for luke you'll be like
actually no i [ __ ] bail no no i have
to make sure someone else is there with
me in case they throw up but i will be
there
and then elo of course we have one for
you
do we have a few for you
um ela
is a kind of woman that tries to help
you out in the girl's bathroom when you
have had too many oh get some other type
of compliment there
you're the type of woman to spike your
drink with water when you're slurring
your words
[Laughter]
[Music]
i guess
yeah a little weird can't say that i
ever done that though yeah i don't think
anyone should ever do that ethan clyne
the type of woman that will build up her
friends and celebrate their success wow
wow
wow
that's really nice meanwhile what'd they
say about me even the type of dude will
float when you smell pie
[Laughter]
you're such a [ __ ]
what did i do you call me a [ __ ]
um when did they say that
probably about ricegum or keemstar it
was it was about um
yeah yeah we're about to get on a flight
actually
and we thought well wikifeet needs to
add a no-fly uh list
because this this is what's going on on
the airplanes these days oh
wow the little toesies bruh this is a
real picture oh yeah that's real
brother little danglies man this thing's
coming out at you at the dark enough to
give a man a heart attack i've never
seen a foot go all the way through the
chair yeah but you ever seen a foot like
that on top of it no
i want to smell feet
[Laughter]
so
hopefully uh
so we uh i know you guys have a flight
to catch so we're on a little bit of a
deadline today and we probably only have
30 to 40 more minutes in the show so we
should let's probably get to the
headline story okay but um um yeah the
hall pass conversation i want to have so
bad okay well
i'm gonna run to the bathroom i'll wait
for you then because the hall pass one's
really good yeah um while ela is uh
doing that
there was a really interesting story
that came out from elijah woods star of
lord of the rings he said that one of
the orcs was actually modeled after
harvey weinstein and what's really
interesting is they're able to identify
the exact work and here you can see the
comparison
do you see it
i thought i no laugh i love this [ __ ]
bro it looks ju oh [ __ ] that's wait is
that harvey weinstein that
that actually looks like ryan cavanaugh
the ceo of triller
no that's that's harvey dude [ __ ] that's
ryan cavanaugh yeah it's weird because
he looks just like the orc dan i think
you need glasses man that that's clear
harvey weinstein that's
that's ryan cavanaugh wow that's the man
who's suing ethan
this is okay so wait let me try okay
that is ryan cavanaugh yeah let me do
the real comparison
or well let me do the one with her with
this is harvey right
that would that would be harvey
weinstein
there is a stunning resemblance right
isn't elijah wood a fan of the show
or he responded to one of our tweets or
something what yeah not to my recounting
i feel like i would have remembered that
elijah the goat our music
that's what it was oh yeah you were
whenever
he was yeah
he's a fan of uh
one of those much cooler dudes
but he watches them
elijah woods watched one of our podcasts
that i was in thank you love
all right
all right ela's back so
here's a conversation
now in israel let me ask you because
you're the only person here who didn't
grow up in america okay
did you have hall passes
what is that
explain
you've already outed yourself
here here's the tick tock that started a
whole conversation here
so i've just found something out about
america that i have never heard before
and i can't believe it so it turns out
if kids want to go to the toilet in
school they have to ask their teachers
for a permission slip apparently it's
called a hall pass and they'll be
walking down the corridor and teachers
will be like have you got a half pass
and they'll be like yeah and it's
literally like a willy wonka's golden
ticket
just
i guess just asking for permission to
get to the bathroom
sorry i just got note that um
actually it looks like ryan cavanaugh oh
is being cast in the upcoming
the amazon uh lord of the rings
and what's interesting about ryan
cavanaugh is that he doesn't even need
makeup he naturally just
fits right in well good for him he need
he needs the gig he for sure is hurting
all right isn't it amazing how he
doesn't need makeup to fit in with the
orcs and trolls and goblins
that is amazing
i am amazed he's like a pr he's like a
natural they're like dude get in there
bro you don't even need hair makeup
just for context in the uk
uh any school man even high school yeah
oh we didn't have hall passes at my high
school i didn't have them either yeah we
did you're both private school kids
aren't you yeah
there it is
you went to private i did what the [ __ ]
you guys are you guys are stuck up
snooties
wait zach you went to private
what i won't go to private school it's
not like for like rich ass kids are you
guys all like rich kids
yes what the [ __ ] why are you guys
sitting next to me
i don't know i just i never met private
school kids before how did you not know
that about zach he's talked about it
i've talked to him
you never stop went to high school with
the jennifer yeah
yeah they trust kids in private school
yeah public schools a whole different
game hell no so wait
so zach and olivia went private yes
ian were you uh private no no no so you
all had you all you publix oh yeah la la
usd baby that was public we had hall
passes oh yeah oh yeah my senior year i
stole them from three of my teachers i
wondered what i stole three of the
teachers i sold their hall passes i want
to get all six of my teachers when i got
three
but does it mean that you still they
have it's
physical
a
physical
gonna get into that yes yeah you see you
see you didn't know what crazy americans
are yes love what were you saying yeah
what'd you say
i'm private too
are you in school right now wait oh
private schools are free in sweden so
it's a little different wait what's the
difference then
well it's probably subsidized by the
state but it's still a private
institution yeah
they need to go by some rules but they
can do they're they're more free
yeah i mean here to go to private high
school you have to be pretty jacked
well
for
generally they have scholarships and
stuff of course but scholars these
[ __ ] ain't getting scholarships
it's rude i mean not that you're not
because you're because you're not poor i
think is what i meant oh
because we're not i'm not smart
no i wasn't that's not what i meant no i
meant because you're not poor i had a
very loving grandmother that's all i'm
gonna say me too actually zach nana sent
your ass [ __ ] my grandma didn't leave me
[ __ ]
yeah my money nona yeah my grandma let
me trauma
i don't think i'm going to hell because
well result the result of that mine does
too so i mean we're in the same boat
here
yeah
well so this hits home here we go
go to the toilet if a teacher sees you
walking down the corridor they're just
like all right mate like they they don't
care
why do they police it like that in
america aren't you supposed to be the
land of the free
pass
so i've just found something else but
okay so i don't know if it's just
because america like
we're more degenerate i mean but it
sounds like your high school was pretty
rough too and they didn't you could just
go to the bathroom whenever you wanted
yeah you just get up and go to the
bathroom and the teacher didn't ask you
[ __ ]
they assume you're going to the bathroom
interesting you come back god america is
so [ __ ]
did they let multiple people go to the
bathroom at the same time um
probably not i don't remember but i feel
like
it would be silly to ask
well if someone was in the bathroom
already i'd this is something that we
had to do is someone is in the bathroom
already you have to wait until they come
back to go that's all it was like i
think yeah yeah maybe that was like the
rule probably for some reason i'm not
even remembering but
i don't i think you had to ask
permission to go to the [ __ ] bathroom
when i was in high school oh yeah no for
sure this whole hall pass you'll be like
and it's in bear and it's like yeah
you know i'm i'm almost an adult yeah
right
exactly that's why i asked at what age
because like maybe when you're like
specifically five or six well then then
the trend continues so what again maybe
you don't know is that there's physical
objects you have to carry that i know
and into the bathrooms and they're
usually quite large and so you don't
steal it right yeah yeah so did you guys
did you have hall monitors too yes was
that a thing well the security guard
well in middle school it was like
students but in high school it was
actually security guards right really in
the hallway and hall motors is some real
gestapo [ __ ] yeah oh always
they never made the kids go against each
other in my school yeah we we it was
either like the school cops or somebody
like that took that job you're like
you're basically like takashi 6'9 at
that point
am i like kindergarten to eighth grade
we had hall passes and if teachers were
just walking in the hallway they would
ask you
body slam you okay
against the locker room i never had the
hall passes i was i'm like i'm gonna
take a piss now like you can't stop me
the worst part is if you're interested
wait this explains a lot about zach's
whole swag about using the faculty
bathroom and stuff you're public bro you
try you're private you try that in a
public bathroom the cops are going to
arrest you no i mean they'll [ __ ] around
they'll teach you something armed guards
will come the teachers at my school were
hard asses i'm not denying that but
well paid hard asses
right but you would get in trouble you'd
get sent to the dean the principal
i just i just won the faculty i don't
give a [ __ ] he was just so such a rebel
cool so
you would have some guards walking
around that's bizarre dude i'm telling
you man school public school is a weird
place well it's even worse now because
i'm sure it's way worse you know people
go there with guns and just like
yeah i'm from that never happened
which is also pretty messed up but no
you don't have stuff like that there's
just a guard at the entrance that's it
right and it's like a nice old guy it's
not like a scary guy right yeah
well here's some tick tocks of the hall
passes people use
so here you go you're gonna get freaked
out by this [ __ ] hilo
no you think you're a whole bed
it's a giant rooster
you can't hear me yeah that makes sense
to me
like i didn't specifically have a
rooster but but large weird objects like
that as the hall pass for sure yeah the
theory is that
why
so you don't steal it you don't feel it
because it yeah yeah or it doesn't go
missing right they put belts why do you
need to hold anything yeah they put good
clothes on it they put a tracking beacon
also think about it ever since covered
like camera of course how dirty that
thing is oh my god bro they were always
disgusting because they come in the
bathroom they come out of the back yeah
what the [ __ ] now you hold it like this
here's another one my bio teachers hall
pass
these fruity pebble macaroons i've never
seen that straight up shook the house
houston
if you wait there's like notes on it all
right if you sprinkle when you tinkle
please
and wipe the seat wait it's a toilet
seat yeah it looks like it is a toilet
seat yeah oh
dude
holy [ __ ]
i yeah i mean look at this kid he's like
a grown-up basically yeah no he's in
high school why do you need to why do
you need to ask oh he says he even goes
oh
he says beverly hills can that be true
yeah
yeah still public school
action yeah uh another one here
yeah this is really mind blowing
everyone's saying like this is par for
the course and the comments are people
surprised
well not people from other countries
yeah in our chat
yeah in america i think everyone
everyone from here says that's what they
have that's how we do it baby but like
uh everywhere everywhere else they say
they don't canada doesn't
yeah anyone's saying wouldn't i mean our
society has fallen so far but that is
very weird for america like america is
the one place where people kind of trust
each other i thought
hell no no have you seen those people
around here but well i don't know i'm
the civil war's coming that's very
american the civil war started in the
halls of my school
the worst part is if you had a foreign
language class you had to ask in that
language
and i had a spanish teacher that
wouldn't let me until i learned the
phrase i i remember there was some [ __ ]
like that and uh
i i think i was taking a lot in class or
some [ __ ] and they're like oh you're
going to sit in latin i'm like you can't
even speak latin
dead language dude that's such a private
school flex latin yeah you're wait yeah
you're link i didn't even like register
that your your foreign language was like
you could take latin olivia were you
given this option too
yeah i know kids from public school also
did live
in public
in case you guys need to perform an
exorcism or something yeah [ __ ] yeah
dude hit us up no to learn like
derivatives of words yeah it's the it's
the origin of the
value
that was not offered at my school no
definitely not
they could barely afford to do spanish
classes if you guys got any demons i can
help you out all right well here's this
guy's uh
a giant a i mean i've seen worse
nothing to complain about it's just so
weird
also like what is the guard supposed to
think you just take some big weird
object and they'll be like okay yeah
you're good
here's another one
it is the leg of
a
giant leg of a
torso
it's like from the movie christmas story
yeah i hate that by the way somebody uh
just made a comment that made me curious
so i went and looked it up you made a
just a passing comment earlier about the
private school teachers making money
apparently that's not true apparently
private school teachers generally make
less than public schools why the [ __ ]
would you work there then i don't know
with all these with all these but i mean
public school teachers have a really
strong union so that's not actually that
surprising that they i mean it's it's a
decent i mean i still think that
teachers are underpaid but i mean they
have good benefits and stuff as teachers
and everything so
my brother now is teaching at a um
at a private school i think it's for is
it public or private is it maybe a
charter school which is kind of like a
weird in between well he told me his
salary and i was like kind of like
that's not that bad
yeah i mean again teachers are saying
should be paid more but um it's not it's
not the worst gig does he have all
passes i was i'm sure he does yeah
apparently his kids are degenerates he
tells me
hopefully they're not watching not his
personality no not his students but his
students are all obviously
yeah
here's another one
well i asked him i said sean uh are
people stealing [ __ ] in the bathroom at
your school he goes oh yeah everything's
[ __ ]
everything's gone the bathroom's
everything that's like all schools after
that stupid
a whole challenge
so when i was in high school one of my
teachers used a trash can as their hall
pass no
bathroom you had to carry the
classroom trash can through the hallway
no no anyway i was taking a video of one
of my friends in our class and in the
doorway you can see a sixth or seventh
grader walking by just carrying a trash
can through the hallway i know the
funniest thing ever to me
anyway i'm gonna go see if i have that
video
i will
side note yes
my high school was 6th through 12th
grade
we love rural america that's middle to
high school yo where's the [ __ ] i got to
find the video
that is so crazy
let's see did you find the video
here it is i found the video
alright so just watch the door right
here
[Laughter]
oh that's so big
that's incredible
dude i can't believe it holy [ __ ]
this person had to carry a crossing
sign
why not just a ball and chain
just fasten the ball and chain to the
leg
i win the hall pass
what is this
what
wow it's like one of those crossing
guards god this is so stupid it's kind
of epic at least it's like
not a random object i mean and put some
thought into that one
oh actually
you're gonna carry that with you yeah
and then like you got to put it and
bring it in the stall or you could leave
it outside but you know that whole
bathroom is just
it's a sanitary nightmare yeah totally
you don't want to bring things in and
out of the bathroom you leave things in
the bathroom
you come out empty-handed yep you know
how much [ __ ] fecal matter is on that
matter matter
like it's just [ __ ] that's sweden
slander how dare you
you don't bring things out of the
bathroom the purpose is just so that if
somebody else sees you they know what
you're doing like the guard or yeah you
have two different lives
so they know you're not messing around
outside class so you couldn't like sneak
around of class basically i don't know
bro they shoot people on site well
that's not true
i don't know what you're asking shoot to
kill
i know your id yeah
i would i
i managed to ditch class a lot in high
school so it wasn't that strict but
the guard straight posted up with
[ __ ]
like that
brutal out those out there
all right well we're running it low on
time so let's talk about in catholic
school we just had to raise our hand and
ask which seems
right normal
yeah
yeah well those catholics ain't got
everything figured out do they
start bragging about catholics going out
oh they got the bathroom thing they got
the bathroom thing figured out at least
yeah wow
easy
as long as someone else is in there
waiting for him
and the spirit
can
is shannon here yes can we get a saudi
in the house please do we have something
sodium
hi shannon
that's me every time i need something
okay so let's talk about basically shane
there's shane dawson and i also wanted
to talk about the god the lamborghini
story so good how much time do we have
and also god there's so many good i mean
you wanted to leave by one
oh
[ __ ] so
well let's do shane because it's
literally the title of the episode and
in the thumbnail so let's let's make
sure we do that one and if we have since
when do we have to talk about things in
the title and thumbnail
i'm kidding i'm kidding
well there's so many good things to get
to man okay
um
so shane is back i watched the whole
[ __ ] thing
olivia you liked it not to throw you
under the bus but i do i am curious what
you liked about it
um we're honest and open here yes
um
i felt like he
said things that if
hmm you want to watch the cancellation
part
no well yeah if you will hear that
obviously
here he addresses how he's been
okay
so so but like it i guess i was
expecting more of a story but it was
kind of just him rambling i felt like it
was just him rambling and desperately
trying to edit it into something
interesting that's what i felt
i think he's gradually
coming back you know what i mean like he
hasn't made a video a real video in two
years
it really is i've been two years yeah
his last jeffree star video was like
december whoa 2019.
i thought it was one year
he did his jeffree star series and then
his like apology video well i think that
is a pretty long time to kind of
um reflect i agree well i liked what he
said when he said um i didn't leave the
internet because i wanted to hide i left
because i felt like i should
i agree you know the fact that he left
two years ago is
the guy had the decency to at least bail
and take time and reflect and so i think
that's important wait that is respect
for respect in my house was that like a
normal video oh that was like one he was
going to start uh
hor i think this is kind of him
continuing what this
because that was in june 2020 yes and
then he posted his apology video right
well anyway this is the first part of a
series like dude is
the actual content itself is just so
[ __ ] miserable
i guess i'm not a genre of the spook
genre but like this is particularly bad
he he moved to uh
colorado or somewhere
and it's like the dude is so desperate
to make things spooky it's like dude
you're in [ __ ] colorado
living this peaceful beautiful rural
life and all this it's like
you're not gonna find any haunted uh
ranches i don't i don't know but it's
just the whole plot it just seems so
silly like there's one point some people
seem to think that that's wrong that it
wasn't two years that's one year
i don't know just one year
january 2020 so
almost one month after yeah yeah almost
two years and i'm also people are saying
like i don't like olivia anymore i
people are saying that yes i feel
conflicted about it okay hey listen you
guys we appreciate this is honest good
discourse because if you'll notice this
shane video has pretty much
overwhelming support
so still number one on trending too
number one trending like what the [ __ ]
youtube the king of promoting some dog
[ __ ] oh yeah
with peace and love they really are with
peace and love
dude if uh harvey and weinstein made a
video youtuber trend that [ __ ] number
one all week
oj simpson upload a video how i did it
youtube be like number one
to be fair if he did that it probably
would be trending pretty hard that would
be pretty fun
i think people would
be watching that
for better or ores
yeah pretty fire content
but here's one particular part of the
spook fest
that i thought was like is that here
okay here's what i'll say
i'm very very very
disconnected i think i clicked the wrong
link
bear with me here
this is a little were you a big fan of
shane um
yeah
was the whole cancellation thing very
hard to process for you i mean it was
super
surprising when everything came out it
felt very weird
but i mean
when all that happened i felt the same
way as everybody else
it was
disappointing mm-hmm and then i had a
hard time the rest of the weekend yeah i
couldn't even get my way
it is hard to process at all because it
you know it's it's it's very hard it is
very hard
um
well i think they're good ghosts watch
the spooky moment yes
i think my mom's house is haunted and we
have angels looking over us here that's
not one of your angels
he keeps quoting this guy who literally
looks like he has 10 views like a d he
calls himself a demonologist bro
what happened a phd
watch this
awesome oh i don't know what level is he
serious did you
this is this this is important this is
the scariest moment of the
of the oh this is very important get
ready content warning what happened your
mom's house
oh i
are
don't
know
you really i was i was gonna ask you
about that like two hours ago but i was
like i don't know if it's a sensitive
subject i don't know the problem they
don't know what that is
just happened
wait stop you're scaring me so much are
you serious what
i don't know well it's not fresh it's
new it's gonna hurt
no it was there when we were clearly
so that's like a
massive trauma scar
and he's like i don't know i don't know
i'm clumsy they get so scared because
they were just in his basement
this is a horror movie
that's going to be a negative spirit
yeah
seriously
anyway the spook actual spook of it is
just really really bad but uh let's
evaluate the
cancellation
from the person that i was
in my early 20s
to a point where when i see that person
it makes me feel
really sad and sick to my stomach but
some things i've learned over the last
year and a half is
i can't just pretend like that person
didn't exist
so
i've really come to peace with that
and also um i don't want to get too much
into this but because i felt like i i
had made a lot of growth before i got
canceled the last five or six years in
and out of therapy
dealing with stuff i feel like i grew as
a person i feel like i learned a lot i
would never say or do any of those jokes
any of those things
ever that i did back then so it was a
weird thing where like i felt like i got
to love the inspiring music
i don't know bro i
i was never a fan so i guess i have no
emotional uh connection to him
but
[Applause]
i had a hard time watching this video
there are also like some things
obviously that
i'm it's not my
thing to accept an apology from him
like
the black faces yeah but that's not
for me to even
right
so i don't i don't know also like the
thing about the blackface is that like
he did it so many times bro
i know
it was those compilations were so wild
yeah but also the one the ones that were
even the kind of the craziest was the
[ __ ] he did with the fine brothers
yeah that was awesome it was a lot of
stuff obviously yeah
oh
[ __ ] he had like a little doll that was
like a child yeah that was making all
these sexual jokes and they were and it
was just it was so [ __ ] bro
it is weird to think like i listen i
i'm not saying this to excuse jane or
anything but like in that era of you
like the late 2000s early 2010s like
pedophile jokes were like
all over the like everybody thought that
was hilarious they were like
[ __ ] dead babies all the time yeah
all the time and it's weird i mean it's
not i guess it's good i should say but
like
the last decade i feel like there's been
a huge awakening to like oh pedophilia
is like not funny
it's pretty serious and it's a huge
problem um but it's just interesting to
see how much that's
i think it was that in combination with
some of the things he did with like
people
there was just there was just a lot of
[ __ ]
yeah
those compilations were brutal but was
there anything recent was all for like
fairly old i'm not super familiar with
all the
proceeds
i'm pretty sure it was all
pretty
old but
he did say in his video that i thought
was actually
kind of
good as he was like
although i feel so disconnected from who
i used to be
this past two years like i've had to
accept that that was me and that is me
and i mean yeah
that's true
yep you did those things dude
so you know i don't know where the line
of forgiveness uh
yeah
av you can use the mic bro you know
oh no i just i'm just throwing it out
there oh yeah you're donating to me it's
just
bro yeah
it's true thank you bro
it's true that the submit well it well
you said the smith family went after him
with full force and nobody survives that
but he seemed to have survived the smith
family wrath
i feel like that's kind of the
not too um
not to necessarily comment on shane but
more about how these things work on the
internet which is
it's kind of disappointing to see how
people just get away with everything
unless it becomes like super serious um
well like bill cosby had the r word like
you know
60 people and by the way he's out so
that [ __ ] got out i keep
forgetting but cosby is out
i would like to see a redemption arc
bill cosby redemption arc uh shane
documentary that was about the same
shame
it would be called a cup of jello
i'm not mistaken wasn't cosby defending
r kelly too no yeah of course bro
yeah
at one point people go oh cancel
cultural cancer culture cancers ruining
society but then you have people like
shane
you have people like david dobrik
and well david disappeared for like a
month shane
james charles was like
james charles is worse than all of them
can't they these people are unfazed well
they take a little bit of a hit i'd say
but like relatively
i mean i'm kind of surprised i wasn't
sure what to expect but the
kind of overwhelming support for shane
is surprising to me
and um but more so james charles yeah
james he still gets support too thing is
james charles is actively a predator
shane did and said disgusting and
offensive things
james charles is actively a predator
yeah cool i think you make an argument
that what james was doing was worse than
china and this is [ __ ] that's like
happening this is at least at least of
what's publicly known about what the two
did i mean david dobrik kind of is a
danger to society i'll be honest like
he's already back to like trying to
injure his friends and stuff but i guess
everybody's willing in that situation or
well not whole i guess not in the
bro i don't know dave david's a piece
david's a freak bro like seriously
i don't know
shane is worse
shane is worse than james i know
i guess
we should have one of those people
because people always say
yeah lots of people shane is worse than
james i how
i don't think we need to put it on a
who's worse than hope because
what they're doing are different things
wait
james is actively trying to [ __ ]
underage boys
how is it worse than that yeah allegedly
allegedly
i mean i've seen the tax what's alleged
about that right well yeah he contends
that they lied about their age
okay well still try to [ __ ] underage boy
[Music]
you know what i'm saying that's just
about facts
brothers searching for younger people to
be in a relationship with
i would like to i'm i just don't
understand the shayna's worse argument i
understand he's really [ __ ] up but
i mean
you know
unless there's something i'm unaware of
i guess i should say right because i
always was there
well because i didn't follow the chain
cancellation closely to tell you the
truth so like maybe there was something
in there that was as bad as that but a
lot of people of color gave shannon a
second chance but he showed that it
didn't grow as a person and we're tired
of giving me wait oh so people passes
okay so
the comment is that
we gave him a second chance people of
color gave him a second chance but how
did he do something recently
maybe it's about the way he addressed
things is that they felt that um it
wasn't sufficient it wasn't really
understanding i mean that's totally fair
to not feel like the apology's good
enough one critique i had of this like
calling the stuff that he did jokes
where for some people it's not just a
joke he didn't own it enough
that's totally somebody's right if they
were the one that was personally
offended by what he did to not accept
his apology or think that it's
sufficient
and and just to just to clarify saying
that what james did is worse isn't
saying that what shane did isn't bad
like both can be bad
it's just one thing is actively
there
preying
on
things that i feel people can learn and
grow and change from
and then there's certain things where i
feel like
i i'm not i don't know shane i don't
know what what he thinks in his heart
and stuff but like there's other things
where jane james seems to be
like actually pathologically
like uh
fought
also another comment is canceling
someone who is trying to change is like
sending someone to jail without hoping
for rehabilitation you're all animals
wow
it's intense
i hope someone uh but like you were
saying i mean you're all animals
calm down the uh
the whole thing with these like these
cancellations is like you were kind of
alluding to
look at the reception of this i mean
well it's just maybe they're canceled
but like maybe this whole discourse
about canceling and the intensity of it
is a little
i mean is this not evidence that it's a
little overblown i i don't think outside
of people that actually commit crimes
like when when you lump in like somebody
like bill cosby was canceled he wasn't
cancelled he was arrested he was
arrested for being an r worder you know
what i mean like and that's that's
that's not that's
that's not a cancellation that's on a
different level
you know people taking reputational hits
for doing [ __ ] up things is nothing
new
that's always been a thing and maybe
social media makes it seem more intense
but that's very important shane's going
to be fine james is going to be fine
david's going to be fine everybody's
you know you've been canceled ethan
you're fine
canceling well you don't know that well
you're fighting some ways in some ways
you're not fine yeah
but
i think that's the thing that um
cancellation is also it's partly also
how that person is gonna take it and
what they're gonna do about it
themselves like
um
certain people choose to disappear for
longer and they really take it very
seriously and go and reflect i don't
know what shane has done i feel like i
feel like it's gonna take time and just
over time his actions will have to prove
one way or another i don't know i do
feel like he took a responsible amount
of time off though as opposed to david
and james who are like hi sister
back to the excavator
so oh no
but yeah it's like
i mean listen guys there's no
good in a society where people are
irredeemable like people we need to give
people the opportunity to grow
and to change and to redeem themselves
obviously it's everybody's right not to
want to forgive them right like i'm not
saying anyone has to forgive them but
like and yeah i i think i'm not sure how
i feel about him still you know ever
since everything came out i'm not sure
what i feel about him and i'm not gonna
be quick to be like hey shane um but
i don't know he can go on and do his
stuff and i guess we'll see
the thing that i do have a criticism of
his apology in this video
because he first of all he has never
addressed this and this was his big
moment to address it
and the stuff he kept saying was like i
don't want to spend too much time about
it because i'm at peace with it and i
don't want to make my whole life about
this and always talk about this i was
like dude this is one [ __ ] video like
you should need to address responsibly
how
um
you did you basically spent like several
years in blackface
like you need we need to unpack that i
need a little more from you like he
tried to gloss over everything like i'm
okay i don't want to dwell on it i'm
embarrassed it's like bro you gotta do
more than that people in chatter saying
he kissed a child on video did he do
that
at one of his meetups like a love is
like
so much there was a lot of people both
it's really hard to keep up with wait
wait what's the story with yeah i know
there's so much
he was at a fan meetup and i think
the fan asked
him to get to give her a kiss or
something and she did it i think uh
like a dude
i mean they didn't make out but they did
kiss
we have to go soon but i'm having too
much fun love do you want to talk more
about it yeah you know you have a strong
opinion
no i think both james charles and shane
should be off youtube honestly
because
there's so many weird
disgusting old videos of shane with kids
not doing anything super weird but just
giving off really weird it's just well
yeah it's the volume of it like that
like the volume
it's not one video it's not yeah
there's like it's like dozens of dozens
right yeah okay i mean fair enough
and also i saw the one with his cousin
where she he was talking about like
sexual stuff with her that was super
disturbing and he was old enough to know
and she was so young but yeah there's
just the volume of shane see that i'm
not yeah maybe i don't know i don't know
it is
scary because like
with the fame there has to be a
responsibility on his side and if he
doesn't have that
responsibility right you know well i
mean that's ultimately youtube's call uh
of whether or not they want to allow him
to exist well he's number one transition
and i was about to say apparently
they've they've made their intention
clear because the trending page is not
it's not automatic like that oh and
there's somebody behind the trending
page is there 100 curated so that tells
you where they stand on it and so you
know if people really think that he's a
danger and shouldn't be on the platform
they should they should
say that to youtube um
a lot of people also kind of always
it's hard not to bring up janna marbles
because it's just well she's
self-imposed yes exactly and it says in
her case everybody wants her to come
back
but she doesn't
i hate to break you guys but i think
she's just over it i think she's just
retired man
maybe maybe someday she'll miss it well
she she did like a frat she did like a
tiny fraction of stuff that shane did
right like like the the least and then
but she being a responsible yeah
well-intentioned adult
who hasn't done this stuff in forever
put herself
self-imposed sanction on herself that
she needs to get offline
like that that's like
unprecedented levels of maturity from
youtuber
just saying
and so
just saying i don't know man shane is
he's a [ __ ] freak bro that's for sure
how many tony five dollars said ethan
shane effed an animal
oh god i forgot you said i did so many
things just dropped that song
i hold to this day from the first day it
happened that that story was too
detailed to not be that [ __ ]
definitely just on his cat and i hold to
this day that that
that might be enough that might be
enough to to warrant yeah
also i remember he said he was like 17
or something when it happened
i could be wrong but i remember him
being like kind of old i mostly just
remember the tweet which which really is
hold up pull up the tweet if we're going
to talk about we're talking about like
we're talking about all the time
greatest tweets of all time i did not
[ __ ] my cat yeah it's it did not come on
my cat i did not [ __ ] my cat
i'd love to believe you buddy but uh
shane dawson cat tweet
okay i sent it
here yeah perfect uh give me some kind
of dramatic music if you could please uh
or angry music or just set the mood if
you could please uh zack oh no the
picture with it
why'd they have to put the kitty kit
i can't uh i did not [ __ ] my cat
i didn't come on my cat i didn't put my
penis anywhere near my cat
i've never done anything weird with my
cats
i promised myself i wasn't going to make
apology videos after the last year's
thing so i'm just trying to be as short
and honest with this as possible
one of one of questions that sounds like
we're not sure how long that wasn't like
a man that [ __ ] his cat
oh i remember there were so many good
replies too of people like i don't even
know who you are but this man definitely
[ __ ] his cat based off of this tweet
yeah rough time man but like i mean the
overwhelming
i gotta say i was surprised i mean if
you guys want to know i downvoted the
video first thing i did like this
so
if you want to know where i stand that's
interesting that's where i stand
all right we could probably discuss this
for a while longer but you guys are on a
deadline the only thing i'll say is
can we just really quickly hit the um
the fact that youtube rewind is going
bye-bye because cam made a beautiful
tribute to say goodbye to it
it's only a minute long so maybe we
could we could end on that we can't have
nice things
[ __ ] as a community
did this to ourselves
with will smith continues to be one of
the greatest
things that's ever been created on this
job we continue to reference it on a
weekly basis
it was a beautiful piece of content and
then the next year they say [ __ ] this we
probably spent like millions of dollars
on this tens of millions of dollars yeah
they're probably like why are we
spending all this money on something
everyone hates millions
and then
and then the next year they go okay
we're just gonna give you the data
they're like we're gonna do a total 180
and everyone's like [ __ ] you
this is worse than last year pathetic
lazy like [ __ ] they can't do anything
so then this year they said you know
what [ __ ] all you
rewind is over they said the creators
have taken up the mantle like mr beast
and pewdiepie or whoever's they're like
[ __ ] you you do this yourself do it
yourself to be and abe pointed out and
it's true we we were
we piled on there as well absolutely
it's all of our faults we did this yeah
yeah upon reflection that was it was a
mistake i mean it was fun though maybe
maybe you took it too much you wish
careful with you yeah totally totally
but now i realize it was it was like
to loved to love and to have lost
it's it's it's
it is it's a monkey paw wish you know
it's like you didn't realize you had a
good thing until it was gone yeah
everybody dunked on that video and here
we are by the way i wanted to show this
by the way a shane
transcending this was his new thumbnail
super dramatic
and it was just him in his house in a
well-lit house talking about whatever
so such a dramatic thumbnail but i'm not
one this to talk but
anyway here he's transcending into oh no
you got some competition zach
he's he's shame-brained
he's the one in shame in the membrane
one last comment that i saw about the
that like rehabilitation is fine but it
doesn't he doesn't need to be famous you
know
or have the
right to have the platform
the thing is that i i see i see
james charles as an active threat
i don't i obviously don't know shane
but i don't really see he hasn't made
content that's really concerned me in a
long time in his private you don't know
what he's doing with his influence right
it may be dangerous although i have to
assume that probably something would be
coming out like in this day and age if
you [ __ ] around people find out
immediately that's not to say it's not
happening and he's not a danger but
james charles has proven himself to be
an active [ __ ] threat
um
i made a video called it's time to stop
you youtube rewind so [ __ ] me
i am
if you're predatory you don't deserve a
platform yeah
i mean
it's a good point yeah because
but if by the time we'll find out it'll
be too late because there will be
victims to tell us right oh hated that
well in james charles case there are
already victims telling us but yeah and
nobody gives a [ __ ]
uh cam suggested we make a video called
it's time to bring back youtube everyone
okay so where's the so play the the
thing oh it's in the dock uh or i can
play it
uh where is it if you just go to the
youtube rewind section
it's rewind time ah
all right guys it's rewind time a stun
to rewind on rewind a powerful tribute
full screen that [ __ ] be
[Music]
it's uh time
yeah if i control rewind sounds what
cracks me up fortnite
and marquez brownlee
marquez brownlee
there's one thing this video needs
k-pop
[Music]
damn so sad
this is so sad we had so much
[Music]
we had so much going for us oh that's
hot we gave this up for what
the flossing backpack
is a little james charles in space
that's where i'd like to send him it
takes a lot of bravery to be that
horrible i'm so promising oh my god
we've lost so much
we should read the comments
oh god bad suggestion
who the [ __ ] would you suggest that
90 million dislikes
most disliked video in the history best
in peace youtube rewind
you know what's watching this over i
think i understand why youtube canceled
rewind because like half of the people
in that video are [ __ ] like predators
and criminals
like the logan brothers
james charles gabby hannah um it's like
everybody in there is fully [ __ ]
problematic
at best they're like geez
[ __ ] wendy all right we gotta go
we're gonna [ __ ] miss our flight for
christ's sake
well have a great weekend guys there's
gonna be a leftovers on sunday because
the fun never ends here on the hd
podcast channel forever
all right we better go
thank you everyone thanks guys have a
great weekend have a great weekend
and uh jobless and gaps with all the
guests you'll see the best podcasts in
the world take it from me jc over cherry
hp baby we podcast now
you're watching h to the three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three three three you're watching
h two three three three three
[Music]
honestly